you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's program
the row over north sea oil continues as
the government's position on issuing new
licenses is branded indefensible
from discarded tents to glitter face
paint we're looking at the climate
impact of festivals
and turning crisp packets into school
desks in south africa
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show with just weeks to go
until the cop 26 climate summit in
glasgow the government is at the center
of an increasingly heated row over
drilling for fossil fuels in uk waters
the scottish green party whose leaders
could become ministers in hollywood if a
deal with the snp is approved tomorrow
claim allowing the extraction of new oil
and gas in the north sea is quote
downright dangerous
they say there are alternatives as our
climate correspondent hannah thomas
peter reports
we're in the north sea off the coast of
scotland maneuvering in challenging
conditions to get a closer look at a
floating wind turbine
the uk gets around a quarter of its
energy from wind and these are a new
tool in the push for even more
we can see here we've got a great wind
resource a
great water depth for example to develop
offshore floating winds fixed bottom we
see limitations around the 40 meter
water depth mark
approximately
the limitation for a floating turbine is
800 meters water depth
they are a feat of engineering but
only part of the story
the uk is a world leader in wind power
but out here the reality is a little bit
more complicated than that and that's
because underneath the north sea there
are still billions of barrels of oil and
for the moment at least we are set on
extracting them
and as the climate crisis intensifies so
does the political row symbolized by an
oil field called cambo that's due to
receive final government approval for
extraction to begin
the scottish green party newly powerful
after a recent election
is outraged
the uk government's position to continue
oil and gas extraction in the north sea
to issue new licenses is not defensible
it isn't compatible with our countries
signing the paris agreement boris
johnson is being more than negligent i
think he's being downright dangerous it
is dangerous to continue on the path
that we are on millions of lives are at
risk
you thought living through a pandemic
was bad you haven't lived through the
breakdown of your biosphere yet the uk
government doesn't see it that way
whether we export some of that oil and
gas or it's for our own use
much better to have access to that oil
and gas on our doorstep and under our
control so are you saying that the the
un and the international energy agency
are wrong when they say that new oil and
gas extraction is incompatible
with hitting global emissions targets
what i'm saying is our
the uk government's targets for net zero
by 2050 already takes into account
licensed oil and gas fields
not yet sanctioned for extraction
whatever the explanation campaigners say
this issue threatens the moral authority
of the british government
just weeks away from hosting a crucial u
n climate change summit in glasgow that
is something it can ill afford to lose
hannah thomas peter sky news in the
northeast of scotland
and if you want to see a real-time
breakdown of where electricity in great
britain is coming from just head to our
website skynews.com forward slash
climate
now in today's other climate news public
concern about climate change has reached
record levels in britain putting it
second only to the pandemic as a key
worry ipsos mori found 32 percent of
people put climate change the
environment and pollution down as a
major issue in britain double the number
of last month
five projects that will restore over 8
000 hectares of peat land across england
have been announced by the government
cornwall and yorkshire are among the
areas that will benefit from the scheme
peatlands store carbon but the uk's are
so damaged that 23 million tonnes of
carbon dioxide are released every year
and organizers have announced that the
queen will be attending the cot 26
climate conference the event is due to
take place in glasgow this november
after being postponed last year due to
the cover 19 pandemic the summit will
bring together heads of governments
business leaders activists and
scientists
extinction rebellion of course
disruption in london on a fifth day of
mass protests with activists marching
through the city of london the
environmental group says it wants banks
and institutions to stop funding fossil
fuel projects
we've heard a lot about extinction
rebellion over the past week but who are
they and what do they stand for
[Music]
if i wish to just stand here with a
placard people just walk by and nobody's
interested you have to create a
disruption to create the conversation
[Music]
so
[Music]
and on this week's episode of climate
cast we examine whether extinction
rebellions controversial tactics
have helped their cause that's out now
wherever you get your podcasts
well it is the august bank holiday
weekend and that can only mean one thing
festivals reading and leeds cream fields
all points east and carfest are just
some of the events taking place over the
next three days and with so much focus
on the climate crisis many organizers
are working to improve their
sustainability so how do festivals
impact the environment
well according to a greener festival the
average festival goer travels 144 miles
just to get there
in 2019 more than half travel to
festivals by either car or plane
traveling to and from sites tends to
make up the most of a festival's carbon
footprint accounting for eighty percent
of the sector's total emissions so what
makes up the rest well almost two
kilograms of waste per person per day is
generated by those at camping festivals
that drops to less than a kilo at
non-camping events the average festival
uses 2762
cubic meters of water almost 3 million
liters all these factors from the travel
to electricity fuel waste and water mean
the average carbon footprint for a
festival is 2
299 tons
of co2 equivalent
well with me now is claire o'neil she's
the co-founder of agreena festival which
helps events festivals and venues around
the world to become more sustainable
claire thank you so much for talking to
us so how easy is it for these events to
become more sustainable
there are some things that are
definitely easy wins but in many cases
we really depend upon the macro
environment that we exist in so for
example what are the transport networks
what are the waste facilities that we
can use
what are the energy resources that are
available the good news is that we have
been working on this subject for
decades at this stage and the
technologies are really advancing to
help festivals to be more sustainable so
for example we have
batteries that can help to supplement
generators reducing fuel we have more
discussions happening to create
installations of renewable energy such
as solar power that can then connect
back to mains or indeed connecting
festivals directly to maine's power as
well which really helps not only with
not burning fuel on site but also not
transport transporting equipment to the
site as well and is there an appetite
for these festivals for these events to
become more sustainable
unquestionably and it's from every
avenue as well we have the audiences
this is what the audiences want
all of the festival organizers we are
all individuals all of us want to be
more sustainable ultimately we can see
what's happening with our environment we
can see the problems that we have with
waste the problems that we have with
consumption of fossil fuels that are
driving the climate crisis and changing
our weather before our eyes so we have
every individual almost on board with
the project
additionally we've just recently had the
dcms from the department from the
government who deal with arts and
culture and media who are saying that we
must start to incorporate environmental
requirements into licensing for events
and these are very clear signals that we
need to implement sustainability and
have greener festivals greener events of
all types but equally it's it's a joined
up approach so we need to be giving the
right messages to the audience so that
we as an entire society can actually
improve our sustainability
is it expensive for an event to be
greener
in some ways yes because it may be that
there's upfront investments into whether
that's new technology or additional
resources of people and staff and
expertise but in the long term really
what we're looking at to be more
sustainable is to stop wasting resources
so whether that's materials whether it's
reducing the cleanup bills because
there's less waste to dispose of whether
it's reducing water reducing fuel
reducing energy ultimately that's going
to save money in the long run as well as
saving our environment and ultimately
our health
so there are upfront costs but there are
also ways that you can make big savings
today for instance by reducing how much
fuel is consumed by really knowing how
much power you need to run the stages
and the event site
okay claire thank you so much for
talking to us
it's a pleasure now in the latest in our
series of climate diaries we're hearing
from solving seven the female-led ngo
has come up with an innovative new way
to use single-use plastics which would
normally go to landfill by turning crisp
packets into school desks
[Applause]
[Music]
we learned that number 7 plastic doesn't
get collected the waste pickers will
collect a plastic bottle there'll be a
packet of crisps or an empty food
package right next to it and they will
not collect it there's no value to it
for them they have no one to sell it on
to no one buys it it doesn't get my size
holder
[Applause]
you then take the raw material and we
give it to another company that is able
to process it into planks which is then
assembled into desks and delivered to
the schools
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
children that receive a dedicated
writing surface can improve their
educational outcomes by up to 20 percent
[Music]
well that's everything from us this week
but don't forget you can watch our
digital show on snapchat and sky news
igtv in the latest episode we go behind
the scenes of our correspondent adam
parsons coverage of the devastating
floods in germany last month
anna jones will be back with the new
extended climate show from monday the
6th of september thank you for watching
[Music]